[Music]
from the studio that won't let
spider-man team up with anyone else ever
comes the Godfather trilogy of superhero
movies in that the first two are great
and the third one sucks X the original
spider-man trilogy prepared for an epic
superhero trilogy featuring spider-man 1
a story about Peter Parker struggling
with his powers breaking up with Mary
Jane and battling a supervillain who
ultimately kills himself spider-man 2 a
story about Peter Parker's struggling
with his powers breaking up with Mary
Jane and battling the supervillain who
ultimately kills himself and spider-man
3 a story about Peter Parker's
struggling with his powers breaking up
with Mary Jane and battling the
supervillain who ultimately kills
himself wait did they just make the same
movie three times in a row Tobey Maguire
stars as Peter Parker a boy with the
face of a puppy and a voice of a smaller
less threatening puppy I cried like a
baby when you played Cinderella when the
student physicists journalists pizza
delivery boy is bitten by a radioactive
spider blah blah blah
powers ba ba ba goes ba philony with
great power comes great responsibility
yeah dude we get it watch spider-man
soar with his trademark powers of
wall-crawling and web shooting plus a
few more like spider sense occasionally
costume design and spider two years
meet Mary Jane the love of Peters life
and the worst girlfriend ever grow to
hate her snaggletooth face as she cheats
on her boyfriend with spider-man cheats
on her fiancee with Peter Parker and
cheats on Peter Parker with his best
friend you'll wonder why anyone bothers
to save her over and over and over and
over and over and over again
[Music]
ride along as spider-man faces off
against iconic supervillains who despite
billion to one odds all have a personal
relationship with Peter Parker like his
professional mentor Doctor Octopus his
uncle's killer The Sandman his rival
coworker venom his best friend's dad the
Green Goblin and his best friend the
other Green Goblin watches these good
men gone bad struggle with her inner
demons the only way they know how
gulping wait Hilde no no no I'm not a
criminal
the real crime would be not to finish
what we started
imagine if he joined us look his face
looks a lot better with a mask on so
before you catch the next installment of
the hipster reboot settle in for two fun
innocent wrongs about a teenage
superhero and a massive turd that
managed to ruin Peter Parker venom when
Stacy and the entire franchise in one go
No
stop what's happening why are you doing
this please please it's all a vanity
story
spider-man pooping Osborn the Great and
Powerful Kerstin starts when Stefani
will I am two foes
Inspector Gadget bland man groovy ashy
Larry black flubber hand gopher face the
spider-man trilogy worse be sure to
subscribe for more honest trailers
Weiner poke I find your lack of faith
disturbing
who knows what evil lurks in the hearts
of men I am a potato enthusiast I'm
looking for my crotch where is my crotch
don't you wish your girlfriend was hot
like me